This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. I felt like I had lost touch with who I was. That I was somebody else. I was my shadow side or something. I don't know. Have you ever felt as if someone else was writing your story, controlling what you do, shaping how you act. Usually, when this happens, the currents that hold us captive come from the outside world.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。我感觉自己好像失去了自我，变成了另一个人。我仿佛成了自己的阴暗面之类的。我不知道。你是否曾觉得好像有别人在写你的故事，控制你的所作所为，塑造你的举止。通常情况下，当这种情况发生时，将我们囚禁的潮流来自外部世界。
But sometimes external forces can be amplified by the currents inside our own minds, the rules that we've been taught, the mandates that we've internalized. that we've been taught, the mandates that we've internalized. This week on Hidden Brain is surreal story about a very strange con and the scripts inside our heads. I mean, I became a stranger. I was like a hypnotized person.
但有时，外在力量会被我们内心深处的暗流放大，也就是我们被灌输的规则，我们内化了的戒律。我们被灌输的规则，我们内化了的戒律。本周的《隐藏的大脑》讲述了一个关于一场极其离奇的骗局以及我们脑海中剧本的超现实故事。我是说，我变成了一个陌生人。我当时就像一个被催眠的人。
I wasn't me and yet I was. Growing up, Jane Mikkelson's father had a peculiar way of getting Jane and her brother to mine their manners at the dinner table. If one of us put an elbow on the table while we were eating, there was a long metal strap under the table that my father could reach very easily from sitting at the head of the table, and he would pluck it with his thumb like a big guitar string, and the whole table would resonate with this tone. And when we were very little, we thought it was magic. What was this ringing sound supposed to indicate? What was the message when you heard the ringing sound? Oh, the table knew I had put my elbow on it and I had to get it off immediately.
我不是我，却又确实是我。简·米克尔森在成长过程中，她的父亲有一种奇特的方法，让简和她弟弟在饭桌上注意餐桌礼仪。如果我们中的一个人在吃饭时把手肘放在桌子上，桌子底下有一条很长的金属带，我父亲坐在桌子头，伸手就能轻易够到，他会用大拇指像拨吉他大弦一样拨弄它，整个桌子都会产生这种音调共鸣。当我们还很小的时候，我们以为那是魔法。这个铃声原本暗示着什么？当你听到铃声时，传达的信息是什么？哦，桌子知道我把手肘放上去了，我得立刻拿开。
The dinner tableau was part of a larger pattern. No matter what turmoil raged inside the house, everything was communicated like that plucked string under the table. And that led to some very sad aspects in our life, our natural mother left when we were very young. My brother was five and I was three, and we were never supposed to speak of her again. If you didn't talk about bad things, it was as if they didn't happen.
这种饭桌上的情景只是更大模式的一部分。无论屋里爆发怎样的骚乱，一切都是通过桌子底下那根被拨动的弦来传达的。这导致了我们生活中一些非常悲伤的方面，我们的亲生母亲在我们很小的时候就离开了。我弟弟五岁，我三岁，我们再也不能谈论她了。如果你不谈论糟糕的事情，就好像它们没有发生过一样。
It was the 1950s and conformity and domestic tranquility were prized, particularly for women and girls. Jane says her father was also shaped by his family roots in Scandinavia and by his own parents reserved nature. He wanted us to be 100% American kids and yet at the same time he was very powerfully shaped by his parents' former homes in Sweden and Denmark. A few years after Jane's mother left, a new woman entered their lives. Lorraine.
那是20世纪50年代，顺从和家庭宁静备受推崇，尤其是对妇女和女孩而言。简说，她的父亲也受到他在斯堪的纳维亚的家族根源以及他父母内向性格的影响。他希望我们成为百分之百的美洲孩子，但与此同时，他又深受父母在瑞典和丹麦的故居的影响。简的母亲离开几年后，一个新女人进入了他们的生活。洛林。
A very psychologically frail woman who would have a breakdown if we answered back or questioned something that she wanted us to do. We learned very early on not to do that. Jane's father married Lorraine, and Jane quickly learned to read her stepmother's moods. When she was happy and just around the house she'd whistle a little song that she liked or something and that as things grew darker and darker in her mind it would become this kind of...
一个心理非常脆弱的女人，如果我们顶嘴或质疑她想让我们做的事，她就会崩溃。我们很早就学会了不要那样做。简的父亲娶了洛林，简很快学会了揣摩继母的心情。当她高兴并且在屋里转悠时，她会哼一首自己喜欢的小曲之类的，随着她心里的阴霾越来越重，这会变成一种……
That horrible frantic trapped sound. Jane became a target of Lorraine's anxiety and rage. The best way to avoid this Jane learned was to tiptoe around her stepmother, to avoid antagonizing her. Her father constantly underscored this message. Other people's happiness and joy in life is far more important than your own. You're here to take care of them and make sure they're okay and do everything you can, You're here to take care of them and make sure they're okay and do everything you can, not to upset them and to give them happiness.
那种可怕的、狂乱的、被困住的声音。简成了洛林焦虑和愤怒的目标。简了解到，避免这种情况的最好方法就是对继母小心翼翼，避免激怒她。她的父亲不断强调这一点。别人的幸福和生活中的快乐远比你自己的重要。你来这里是为了照顾他们，确保他们安然无恙，竭尽全力，你来这里是为了照顾他们，确保他们安然无恙，竭尽全力，不要惹他们生气，并带给他们快乐。
The scripts we learn in childhood often stay with us as we grow up. By the time Jane was a teenager, she had firmly internalized the family rules. Don't make a fuss. Keep your head down. Put other people first. But Jane was defined, as many of us discover, that the scripts that serve us well in one context can harm us in another. When she was 16, Jane and her friend Nancy went for a swim in a lake near their neighborhood. After an hour or so, a couple of older boys approached the two girls and started flirting with them. It was fun at first, but soon got to be too much. Jane and her friend
我们在童年时期学会的剧本，往往在我们长大后伴随着我们。到了简十几岁的时候，她已经深深地内化了家族规则。不要大惊小怪。低调行事。把别人放在第一位。但正如我们许多人所发现的那样，简被定义了，那些在某种情况下对我们有益的剧本，在另一种情况下可能会伤害我们。当她16岁时，简和她的朋友南希去她们社区附近的一个湖里游泳。大约一个小时后，几个大男孩走近这两个女孩并开始调情。一开始很有趣，但很快就过头了。简和她的朋友
decided to leave and go home. And we're walking up the hill, and I heard something behind me, and we turned around, and there were the two guys. They were tracking us. And I did what my stepmother always told me to do, never make a fuss, you're a lady. The next thing I knew I was faced down in a dirt road. One of the boys had tackled Jane and was trying to rip off her bathing suit. The commotion drew a family down to the lake. The boys ran off and the family took Jane home.
决定离开回家。我们正往山上走，我听到身后有声音，我们转过身，那两个家伙就在那里。他们在跟踪我们。我做了继母一直告诉我的事，绝不大惊小怪，你是个淑女。等我回过神来，我已经面朝下趴在土路上。其中一个男孩把简扑倒，试图撕开她的泳衣。这场骚乱吸引了一个家庭来到湖边。男孩们跑了，那家人把简送回了家。
When I got there, my brother was sitting watching TV and he looked at me and you know I'm shaking, I'm crying and he said are you okay and I said no I'm horrible no I'm not not and I ran up to my bedroom. Her parents got home and he said I think something's happened to Jane better go talk to her. Her parents came upstairs. Jane explained what had happened. I guess my dad called the police because the next thing I knew there was a detective from the Stanford Police Department sitting directly opposite
我到家时，我弟弟正坐在那里看电视，他看着我，你知道我在发抖，我在哭，他说你还好吗，我说不，我糟透了，不，我不好，然后我跑上楼回到卧室。她的父母回到家，他说我想简可能出事了，最好去和她谈谈。她的父母上了楼。简解释了发生的事情。我想我爸爸报警了，因为等我回过神来，斯坦福警察局的一名侦探正坐在我的正对面
me. The detective began asking Jane uncomfortable questions. What did you say to these guys kind of like that old junk about, oh, it's usually the young woman's fault. She probably lured him on, blah, blah. I was in shock and I was terrified. Jane desperately wanted her parents to stand up for her, to put the detective in his place, to say she had done nothing wrong. They just sat there silent, and it was like the most horrible sense of betrayal that nobody was doing anything to ease my fears, and they never mentioned it again. It was over and done with and in good decorum. You don't talk about bad things after they're done.
这位侦探开始问简一些让人难堪的问题。你对这些家伙说了什么？有点像那种老掉牙的废话，哦，通常是年轻女性的错。她可能引诱了他，巴拉巴拉。我处于震惊中，而且惊恐万分。简多么希望她的父母能为她挺身而出，让侦探闭嘴，说她没有做错任何事。他们只是坐在那里一言不发，那种可怕的被背叛感油然而生，没有人做任何事来减轻我的恐惧，他们再也没有提起过这件事。事情已经结束了，符合体统。事情结束后，你不会再谈论糟糕的事情。
Even in extreme situations, the rules of the family were clear. Even in extreme situations, the rules of the family were clear. Tranquility, or at least the appearance of tranquility, was the most important goal. When Jane turned 18, she left for college and all women's school. She thought she would be able to explore a new side of herself. They took great pride in being the first woman's college in the United States to grant a woman a full baccalaureate degree. But college wasn't what she had expected. She had wanted to read literature and act in student plays. Instead she recalls. She got secretarial courses and pleated skirts. I was very unhappy and my stepmother went and had a nervous breakdown, blaming me for upsetting
即使在极端情况下，家族的规则也很明确。即使在极端情况下，家族的规则也很明确。宁静，或者说至少是表面的宁静，是最重要的目标。简18岁时，离家去了一所女子学校。她以为自己能够探索崭新的一面。他们为自己是美国第一所授予女性完整学士学位的女子学院而感到自豪。但大学生活并不像她所期望的那样。她本想阅读文学作品并出演学生戏剧。相反，她回忆道。她学的是秘书课程和百褶裙。我很不高兴，我的继母去精神崩溃了，指责我因为成绩不好而让她心烦意乱
her by getting back grades. And so I just wanted to get out of there and one day I just happened to see a brochure from an organization called Scan and Avan Seminars. The program promised a semester abroad, far from her family, college, and anyone who knew her. So without telling anybody about my fledgling plans, I wrote to them for more information. And when that packet arrived, oh, I can't tell you how many times I took it out and read it over and over again, it was like having a secret lover. again, it was like having a secret lover. The packet contained an application, and it offered candidates a list of former participants who could talk about their experiences in the program.
所以我只想离开那里，有一天我恰好看到了一份来自一个叫做“扫描与安凡研讨会”组织的宣传册。该项目承诺提供一个海外学期，远离她的家庭、大学以及任何认识她的人。于是，在没有告诉任何人我萌芽中的计划的情况下，我写信给他们索取更多信息。当那个包裹到达时，哦，我无法告诉你我多少次把它拿出来一遍又一遍地读，那感觉就像拥有一个秘密情人。那感觉就像拥有一个秘密情人。包裹里有一份申请表，并向候选人提供了一份前参与者的名单，他们可以谈论他们在该项目中的经历。
I mailed right back and I said yes, yes, yes, I'll take the list. When the list of names came back, there were several women on it, but Jane decided to write to a young man. I mean, I really had never had any kind of a deep intimate relationship with a guy. And it wasn't that I was actively looking for one, but a lot of my friends were getting boyfriends, and I don't know, I kind of thought it would be sort of fun if it was a guy. So that's why I chose the guy. We're calling the young man Philip. That's not his real name, but it was the name Jane gave us.
我立刻回信说，好的，好的，好的，我要那份名单。当名单寄回来时，上面有几个女性的名字，但简决定写信给一个年轻男子。我的意思是，我真的从来没有和男生有过任何深刻亲密的关系。并不是我主动在寻找这样的关系，但我的很多朋友都找到了男朋友，我不知道，我有点觉得如果是个男生会挺有意思的。这就是我选择这个男生的原因。我们称这个年轻男子为菲利普。那不是他的真名，但那是简给我们的名字。
We've learned more about Philip as we reported the story, but are choosing to use this name for reasons that will become clear as a story unfolds. Jane wrote to Philip and asked if he would talk with her about his experiences studying abroad. name for reasons that will become clear as the story unfolds. Jane wrote to Philip and asked if he would talk with her about his experiences studying abroad. He wrote back right away, and he answered some of my questions I had asked, and then he asked the name of my hometown. And when his next letter came, he mentioned that he lived not too far away from there.
在我们报道这个故事的过程中，我们对菲利普有了更多的了解，但为了随着故事展开而变得清晰的原因，我们选择使用这个名字。简写信给菲利普，问他是否愿意和她谈谈他海外学习的经历。为了随着故事展开而变得清晰的原因，我们选择使用这个名字。简写信给菲利普，问他是否愿意和她谈谈他海外学习的经历。他立刻回信了，回答了我提出的几个问题，然后他问了我家乡的名字。当他的下一封信寄到时，他提到他住在离那儿不远的地方。
Spring break was coming up, and Philip asked Jane if she would like him to visit her when she was home for the break. She hadn't told her parents about the study abroad program, but she wanted to meet Philip. So she wrote back and said yes. When the date of the meeting rolled around, Jane told her parents a young man was coming to talk to her about some academic study she was exploring. Philip rang the bell, and Jane answered the door. And he stepped in, and I was surprised that he wasn't much taller than I was.
春假就要到了，菲利普问简，当她放假回家时，是否愿意让他来拜访她。她没有把海外留学项目的事告诉父母，但她想见菲利普。于是她回信说好。见面日期临近时，简告诉父母，有一个年轻男子要来找她谈谈她正在探索的一些学术研究。菲利普按了门铃，简去开门。他走了进来，我很惊讶他没有比我高多少。
I had, as I say, kind of built up this mental image of him as being tall, handsome, what have you. He didn't look the way I anticipated. He wore a jacket and a tie and he was super polite. I don't know if there was some kind of aura. This is the polite house. Mind your manners, all ye who enter here. Oh yes, oh yes, we should have had a poster sing that at the end of the drive-way. He called my parents, Mr. and Mrs. and he was very polite, you know, asking, you know, little questions about just how are you and my you have a nice home whatever. But the one thing that struck me
正如我所说，我在脑海中把他的形象构建得很高大、帅气等等。他长得和我想象的不一样。他穿着夹克系着领带，非常有礼貌。我不知道是不是有什么气场。这里是有礼貌的家庭。进入此地的人，皆须注意礼节。哦，是的，哦，是的，我们本该在车道尽头挂一块写着这个的牌子。他称呼我的父母为先生和太太，他非常有礼貌，问一些小问题，比如你最近怎么样，哇，你有个漂亮的家之类的。但让我震惊的一件事是
was how little he revealed of himself. You know, here he was in my home seeing where I lived. I think he knew or sensed much more about me than I did of him. Any hopes Jane had for romance fizzled out as they talked. The most remarkable thing about Philip was that he seemed utterly undremarkable. And there wasn't any like that spark between us, at least not certainly not on my side, and I didn't see or our experience any of that on his. He stayed for a meal and showed Jane some pictures of his time abroad. Then he left and I went back to school and so did he. Jane put Philip out of her mind.
他对自己透露得太少了。你看，他就这样来到我的家里，看到我住的地方。我想他了解或感应到的我，比我了解或感应到的他要多得多。简对浪漫的任何希望在他们交谈时都烟消云散了。菲利普最引人注目的地方在于他显得极其平庸。我们之间没有那种火花，至少从我这边绝对没有，而且我也没看到或体验到他有这种感觉。他吃了一顿饭，给简看了一些他在国外时的照片。然后他走了，我回了学校，他也回了学校。简把菲利普抛到了脑后。
But a couple of months after the visit, one of her dorm mates came to tell her she had a phone call. We didn't have cell phones back then, there was one telephone for an entire floor of girls. Jane walked down the hallway to the small nook where the phone was kept. She answered it. And it was Philip. Jane was shocked, especially after she heard why he was kept. She answered it. And it was Philip. Jane was shocked, especially after she heard why he was calling. He was inviting me to come to his college
但在那次拜访几个月后，她的一个室友来告诉她，她有电话。我们那时候没有手机，整层女生宿舍只有一部电话。简顺着走廊走到放电话的小角落。她接了电话。是菲利普。简感到震惊，尤其是当她听到他打电话的原因后。她接了电话。是菲利普。简感到震惊，尤其是当她听到他打电话的原因后。他邀请我去参加他那年6月的大学
graduation that June. I was more than a little startled. I thought this is a major, major major event in a young person's life. And you don't even know me, really, how strange. But he became quite enthusiastic about it and he said, oh, it's going to be so much fun. You know, this time of year, the campus is beautiful. And you can meet my family and I'm in a fraternity and they're going to have a big graduation party. It's going to be fun. Jane weighed the invitation. It was certainly odd. But then she reflected on what else she had going on in her life, an unexciting waitressing
毕业典礼。我不仅仅是有点吃惊。我想这是一个年轻人生命中非常、非常、非常重大的事件。而且你根本不认识我，真的，太奇怪了。但他对此变得非常热情，他说，哦，那会非常有趣。你知道，一年中的这个时候，校园非常美丽。你可以见见我的家人，我加入了一个兄弟会，他们要举办一个盛大的毕业派对。会很有趣的。简权衡了这个邀请。这确实很奇怪。但随后她反思了自己生活中其他的事情，一份无聊的服务员
job, an emotionally distant family at home, the wide expanse of a boring summer. So I thought, oh, alright, I'll do it. It'll be fun, it'll be an adventure. She got to get the money for the train fare and started making plans for the trip. A few weeks before the graduation weekend, Philip sent her a letter. He had discovered a small problem. There weren't many more tells in his little college town, and the few they did have refused to rent rooms to unmarried students.
工作，家里冷漠的家庭，无聊的漫长夏天。所以我想，哦，好吧，我去吧。这会很有趣，这将是一次冒险。她筹集了火车票的钱，并开始为这次旅行做计划。毕业周末前几周，菲利普寄给她一封信。他发现了一个小问题。他那座大学小镇没有多少汽车旅馆了，仅有的几家拒绝把房间租给未婚学生。
He had come up with a solution, though. He had to tell the motel that we were a married couple. And then he said, but he wouldn't. I would still have the place to myself. He was not going to stay there, but that he was worried I'd be maybe put off by that element of our plans, and that he hoped I'd be okay with that.
不过，他想出了一个解决办法。他不得不告诉汽车旅馆我们是一对已婚夫妇。然后他说，但他不会。我仍然可以独占这个房间。他不会留在那儿，但他担心我可能会对我们计划中的这个环节感到反感，他希望我能接受这一点。
Jane had friends, who do you similar roses? I just was desperate to get away from home, to have some adventures of my own. You know, I should have paid attention to maybe that little alarm bell, but it never rang. So I said, okay, and he reserved the room under his name with me as his wife. room under his name with me as his wife. Jane said OK to Philip when he suggested he visit her home. She said OK when he proposed out of the blue that she attend his graduation. And she said OK when he suggested they registered the motel as a married couple.
简有朋友，谁会经历类似的冒险呢？我只是迫切想要离开家，去经历我自己的冒险。你知道，我本该注意那个小小的警报铃，但它从未响起。所以我说，好吧，他以他的名义预订了房间，我是他的妻子。以他的名义预订了房间，我是他的妻子。当菲利普建议去她家拜访时，简说了好。当他突发奇想求她去参加他的毕业典礼时，她说好。当他建议他们在汽车旅馆登记为已婚夫妇时，她说好。
She didn't realize it but well before she got on that train to Philip's graduation, she was already on a psychological ride. It was now gathering momentum. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. In June 1964, Jane Mikkelson got on a train to go to Philip's graduation. As the New England countryside sped by, she imagined how the weekend might go. Eventually, the train arrived at a tiny stop in New Hampshire. I got off the train and he was right there with a big smile, took my bags,
她没有意识到，但在她登上开往菲利普毕业典礼的火车之前，她就已经踏上了一段心理过山车。现在它正在积聚动能。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。1964年6月，简·米克尔森登上了一列去参加菲利普毕业典礼的火车。随着新罕布什尔州的乡村风景飞速掠过，她想象着这个周末会怎么过。终于，火车到达了新罕布什尔州的一个小站。我下了火车，他就在那里带着灿烂的笑容，拿了我的行李，
and he had rented a silver Impala for the weekend so that he could drive me back and forth from the train and around the campus. And he put my suitcase in and then he helped me. could drive me back and forth from the train around the campus. And he put my suitcase in, and then he helped me. I mean, he was such a perfect gentleman. He helped me into the passenger side, and then he got in on the driver's side. And I thought, we were going to, oh, he's going to start the car, and we're going to drive to the campus
他租了一辆银色英帕拉轿车过周末，这样他就可以开车送我往返于火车站和校园之间。他把我的行李箱放进去，然后帮我。开车送我往返于火车站和校园之间。他把我的行李箱放进去，然后帮我。我的意思是，他真是一位完美的绅士。他帮我坐进副驾驶座，然后自己坐到驾驶座上。心想，我们要，哦，他要发动汽车，我们要开往校园
or wherever. And instead, he turns, and he gives me this big smile. And he told me to stick out my left hand. So I did, oh God, I was so obedient, it scares me. And he took my left hand and he slipped an engagement ring onto my left finger, you know, the ring finger. And he said, now we're engaged and then he pulled out a wedding band and he added it to that and he said and now we're married because we have to look like we're really married and if you come in without any rings on your wedding finger. It's called, look weird. And we laughed and laughed. But I laughed,
或者其他地方。相反，他转过身，向我露出了灿烂的笑容。他让我伸出左手。于是我照做了，天哪，我太听话了，这让我感到害怕。他拉起我的左手，把一枚订婚戒指套在我的左手上，你知道的，无名指。他说，现在我们订婚了，然后他掏出一枚结婚戒指戴在上面，接着说，现在我们结婚了，因为我们必须看起来像真的结婚了，如果你手上不戴着婚戒来。这会显得很奇怪。我们笑了又笑。但我笑，
I have to say more out of kind of not fear, but I found it more uncomfortable than hilarious, but I was trying to be a good sport. And this was where that bell did begin to ring, but I still played dumb. When they got to the motel, Philip helped get her bags to her room. He said, now I'm going back to the fraternity house and there's going to be this big party. And so why don't you get, you know, freshen up from your trip and get ready to go to a really fun party? Jane did as she was told. She put on a dress and did her makeup.
我必须说，与其说是出于恐惧，不如说我发现这与其说是滑稽，不如说是让人难堪，但我一直在努力表现得大度。也就是在这个时候，那个铃声开始响起，但我仍然装傻。到了汽车旅馆，菲利普帮她把行李拿到房间。他说，现在我要回兄弟会那儿去，那里会有一个盛大的派对。所以，你为什么不收拾一下旅途的风尘，准备去参加一个非常有趣的派对呢？简照做了。她穿上一条裙子，化了妆。
She thought about the flat parties she'd been to before. She knew they could get a little rowdy. But she felt sure Philipp wouldn't let things go too far. He was such a gentleman I knew that he would be by my side and keeping an eye out for me. Soon, Philip was back in the server in Pala. And it was a glorious evening. Everything was so lush and green and flowering and it wasn't much of a drive, maybe ten minutes. And then he turned into this long driveway. And there was this beautiful house.
她想起自己以前去过的那些平淡的派对。她知道那些派对可能会有点喧闹。但她确信菲利普不会让事情太过分。他是个真正的绅士，我知道他会陪在我身边照顾我的。很快，菲利普开着银色英帕拉回来了。那是一个美妙的夜晚。一切都是那么郁郁葱葱、绿意盎然、繁花似锦，车程不远，大概十分钟。然后他拐进了一条长长的车道。那里有一栋漂亮的房子。
And the doors were open, the windows were open, and music was pouring out. I just felt pretty and excited at that point. I just felt pretty and excited at that point. He gets out first. I knew he was going to, of course, because he was such a gentleman, and then he opened my side of the car, and he put his hand in to help me out. And then when I got out, he tucked my arm into the crook of his arm and he seemed to get a little taller and he was kind of like more formal all of a sudden and then he walks me up to the stairs and and kind of almost ceremonial fashion. We walk up the stairs and we're kind of laughing about being so proper and we walked in the door across the threshold. Right in front of them was a wall of young men
门开着，窗户开着，音乐倾泻而出。那一刻，我只觉得漂亮而兴奋。那一刻，我只觉得漂亮而兴奋。他先下车。我知道他会这样，当然，因为他是个绅士，然后他打开我这边的车门，把手伸进来扶我出去。等我下车后，他把我的胳膊挽进他的臂弯里，他似乎长高了一点，突然之间变得更加正式了，然后他带我走上台阶，以一种几乎是仪式的姿态。我们走上台阶，我们有点笑着嘲笑自己如此拘礼，我们走进门，跨过门槛。正对着他们的是一堵年轻男子的墙
dressed in navy blazers and khaki pants. But the minute we walked in the door, they parted like the red sea opening, my dear. They parted like the red sea opening my dear and they were shouting surprise And when they stepped aside like that I saw one of these long banquet tables and Right in the center of the table
穿着海军蓝西装外套和卡其裤。但我们一进门，他们就像红海裂开一样分开了，亲爱的。他们就像红海裂开一样分开了，亲爱的，他们在大喊“惊喜”！当他们让开时，我看到一张长长的宴会桌，在桌子的正中央
was a three-layer wedding cake with a little plastic bride and groom on the top. I was stunned. I could barely breathe. I thought maybe this is for somebody else, but no, I mean, it wasn't. You know, everybody was coming forward and slapping Philip on the back, shaking his hands, and some of the guys were coming over to kiss the bride. And then they started playing the wedding march. And did you see anything? Did you look at him? Did you exchange anything with Philip?
是一个三层结婚蛋糕，上面有一个小塑料新郎新娘。我惊呆了。我几乎无法呼吸。我想也许这是给别人的，但没有，我的意思是，事实并非如此。你知道，每个人都走上前去拍打菲利普的背，同他握手，有些家伙走过来亲吻新娘。然后他们开始演奏婚礼进行曲。你看到了什么吗？你看着他了吗？你和菲利普交换了什么吗？
No, no, no. I was so stunned. I just froze. If I'd been more self-assured, more mature, what I could have done was laugh and then say, oh, you guys, he really got you, didn't he? You know, we're not married. Come on. But I was too polite. Jane couldn't figure out if Philip was pulling an elaborate prank on his fraternity brothers. That had to be it, right? But as she watched Philip's face, she sensed this wasn't a joke.
没有，没有，没有。我太震惊了。我只是僵住了。如果我更自信、更成熟一点，我本可以大笑然后说：“哦，你们这些家伙，他真的把你们骗了，不是吗？你知道，我们没有结婚。得了吧。”但我太礼貌了。简无法弄清菲利普是不是在对他的兄弟会兄弟们搞一个精心策划的恶作剧。一定是的，对吧？但当她看着菲利普的脸时，她感觉到这绝不是一个玩笑。
But as she watched Philip's face, she sensed this wasn't a joke. He was so thrilled, he was laughing and you know just thrilled and from a couple of the comments I knew he was the one of the first to tie the knot, you know. I had no idea how to respond. None, none, How do you? How do you respond to something like that? So, what happens next? The party now is basically getting underway. What happens next? Are they toasts or celebrations? What happens? Oh, my goodness, yes. They came around with glasses of champagne. Philip gave a toast to his new bride. And the other, I don't know, one or two of the fraternity brothers proposed a toast.
但当她看着菲利普的脸时，她感觉到这绝不是一个玩笑。他太兴奋了，他一直在笑，你知道的，就是那种欣喜若狂，从他的几句评论中我知道他是第一批成家的人之一，你知道的。我不知道该如何回应。完全不知道，完全不知道，你怎么回应？你怎么对那样的事情做出回应？那么，接下来发生了什么？派对现在基本上开始了。接下来发生什么？有祝酒或庆祝活动吗？发生了什么？哦，天哪，是的。他们端着香槟酒走过来。菲利普为他的新娘祝酒。然后其他兄弟会的兄弟，我不知道，有一两个提出了祝酒。
And I just drank that champagne down like it was ice water, zip, zip, and somebody gave me another. After a few more glasses of champagne, one of the fraternity brothers led Jane outside. He looked quite serious. Everybody else was laughing and talking and drinking champagne and beer. And he very bluntly said, are you really married to him? You really married him. And I just didn't know what to say. Jane's mind began to race. Should she tell him?
我一口就把那杯香槟像冰水一样喝下去了，咕咚咕咚，然后有人又给了我一杯。又喝了几杯香槟后，其中一个兄弟会的兄弟把简带到了外面。他看起来很严肃。其他所有人都在笑、聊天、喝香槟和啤酒。他非常直白地问：你真的嫁给他了吗？你真的嫁给他了。我简直不知道该说什么。简的脑子开始飞速运转。她应该告诉他吗？
Or should she lie to save Philip's reputation? But the very fact that I didn't answer told this guy what he wanted to know. And he then told me that Philip was a really good guy, but he is a little different and he's had a bit of a rough time fitting in. And this marriage clearly means a lot to him. And you'll never see any of these guys again after this weekend. Why not play along with him? Don't humiliate him. More than 50 years have passed since that moment. Jane actually has two distinct memories about what the young man said to her. She can't be sure which one is real. In the second
还是应该撒谎来维护菲利普的名誉？但我不回答的事实本身就告诉了这个家伙他想知道的。然后他告诉我，菲利普是个非常好的家伙，但他有点与众不同，融入集体经历了一点坎坷。这段婚姻对他的意义显然非常重大。这个周末过后，你再也不会见到这些家伙中的任何一个了。为什么不顺着他演下去呢？不要羞辱他。距离那一刻已经过去50多年了。关于那个年轻对她说了什么，简其实有两种截然不同的记忆。她无法确定哪一个才是真的。在第二个
version, same guy, you know, also telling me that maybe Philip did this to kind of gain some prestige with his fraternity brothers and his friends, and that he would feel more important or whatever if he had been the first of the fraternity brothers that year to get married. But that was deception. I would be fostering Phillips deception and that I really shouldn't do that. Jane can't be sure which version is accurate,
版本里，还是同一个家伙，你知道的，也告诉我，也许菲利普这样做是为了在兄弟会兄弟和朋友们面前获得一些声望，如果他是当年兄弟会里第一个结婚的人，他会觉得自己更重要或者别的什么。但那是欺骗。我将助长菲利普的欺骗行为，我真的不应该那样做。简无法确定哪个版本是准确的，
but her recollection of what she chose to do next is crystal clear. You know, when you grow up not being allowed to get angry, you don't get angry. not being allowed to get angry? You don't get angry. Jane went back to the party. Her memory of the rest of the evening is hazy, possibly because of the amount of champagne she had drunk. But the celebration must have died down at some point.
但她对接下来自己选择做什么的记忆却清晰无比。你知道，当你从小就不被允许生气时，你便不会生气。不被允许生气？你不会生气。简回到了派对上。她对当晚剩下时间的记忆很模糊，可能是因为她喝了太多香槟。但庆祝活动在某个时刻肯定已经平息了。
She must have gotten into the silver empala with Philip. He must have driven her back to the motel. He must have helped her up to the room. She remembers he came up to the room with her because she has a vivid memory of throwing up in the bathroom. I was kneeling in front of the toilet and Philip was holding my hair back. And later on, I wondered,
她一定和菲利普上了那辆银色英帕拉。他一定开车送她回了汽车旅馆。他一定帮她回到了房间。她记得他跟着她回了房间，因为她对自己在浴室里呕吐有鲜明的记忆。我跪在马桶前，菲利普扶着我的头发。后来我想，
wonder who taught him to do that. Jane doesn't remember changing out of her clothes or going to bed. Later on, I wondered, wonder who taught him to do that. Jane doesn't remember changing out of her clothes or going to bed. She doesn't remember a conversation with Philip about whether he could stay the night in her room. She doesn't recall Philip getting into bed with her, except he must have, because she clearly remembers what happened when she woke up. Remember waking up the next morning with one of my life's worst hangovers. I was just so sick to my stomach
我想知道是谁教他这么做的。简不记得自己换下衣服或上床睡觉了。后来我想，我想知道是谁教他这么做的。简不记得自己换下衣服或上床睡觉了。她不记得和菲利普谈过他是否可以在她的房间过夜。她不记得菲利普上了她的床，除了他一定这么做了，因为她清楚地记得醒来时发生了什么。记得第二天早上醒来时，我经历了人生中最严重的宿醉之一。我只是胃里难受得要命
and then I turned over and he was there. And that was startling because he had told me that I would have that room to myself. But luckily, he hadn't done anything. I think he even may have slept on the outside of the bedding. And did you have a conversation about why he was there or what happened? No. It's so strange.
然后我翻了个身，他就在那里。这让人大吃一惊，因为他曾告诉我，我可以独占那个房间。但幸运的是，他什么也没做。我想他甚至可能睡在被子外面。你们有没有谈过他为什么会在那儿或者发生了什么？没有。这太奇怪了。
You know, I never had any modeling for challenging people, for contradicting people, for being angry at people in an appropriate way. We just weren't raised like that, and at that point I felt so deep in it. I thought, let's just get this over with. Once his family's here, this will end, because his family knows he's not married. It's just something he's done for his fraternity brothers to, you know, to have fun or go off on a big bang with his college years. So I kind of put myself in neutral and went along. Philip gave her a tour of campus
你知道，我从来没有受过如何挑战别人、如何反驳别人、如何以适当方式对别人生气的训练。我们根本不是那样长大的，当时我感到自己陷得太深了。心想，赶紧把这事了结了吧。一旦他的家人来了，这一切就会结束，因为他的家人知道他没有结婚。这只是他为了兄弟会兄弟们，你知道的，为了好玩或者让他的大学生活轰轰烈烈地结束而做的事情。所以我有点让自己处于空挡状态，随波逐流了。菲利普带她参观了校园
and took her out for lunch, acting as if nothing had happened. At every step, as Jane went along, more and more people were swept up in the story. And it became harder and harder to say, stop, this isn't true, I want out. Philip had written a play and recruited a number of unwitting actors to play roles in it. Jane was in one of the lead roles, but she wasn't alone. The desk clerk at the motel had signed off on them being married. Philip's fraternity brothers had planned an elaborate celebration, complete with a three layered wedding cake.
并带她去吃午饭，表现得好像什么都没发生过一样。每一步，随着简的随波逐流，越来越多的人被卷入这个故事中。而要想说“停，这不是真的，我想退出”变得越来越难。菲利普写了一部剧本，并招募了许多不知情的演员在其中扮演角色。简是主角之一，但她并不孤单。汽车旅馆的前台文员在他们已婚的文件上签了字。菲利普的兄弟会兄弟们策划了一场精心布置的庆祝活动，甚至准备了一个三层结婚蛋糕。
Philip had spent the night with her and they had woken up in the same bed like an actual couple. Psychologists sometimes talk about a concept known as social proof. When everyone around you believes something, says something or acts in a certain way, it's hard to step outside that shared narrative. And the more people fail to question an unfolding narrative, the more that story gathers momentum. The harder it becomes to stop. I mean, I felt helpless in a way. I felt I was kind of being swept along in a really scary current. I didn't know what to do.
菲利普和她过夜，他们在同一张床上醒来，就像真正的一对夫妻一样。心理学家有时会谈到一个被称为“社会认同”的概念。当周围每个人都相信某事、说某种话或以某种方式行事时，很难跳出那个共同的叙事。而当越来越多的人对正在展开的叙事不加质疑时，那个故事就会积聚越来越多的动能。想要停下来就变得越困难。我的意思是，某种程度上我感到无助。我觉得自己被卷入了一股非常可怕的暗流中。我不知道该怎么办。
I didn't even bring enough money to get a cab back to the train station if I needed to leave right then and there. Like all of us in difficult situations, Jane fell back on her coping mechanisms. Except in this case, Jane's primary coping mechanism was the lessons she had learned as a child. Go along, get along, don't make a fuss. By the time they got back to the motel that evening,
我甚至没有带足够的钱来在需要立刻离开时坐出租车去火车站。就像我们在困境中的所有人一样，简退回到了她的应对机制。只不过在这个时候，简主要的应对机制是她童年学到的教训：随大流，合群，别大惊小怪。当他们那天晚上回到汽车旅馆时，
Jane was in full fake bride mode. When Philip accompanied her into the motel room, she didn't tell him to go away. He had brought her record player to this motel room that obviously was now ours, not mine. There was a TV show called Dr. Kildir, and this actor, Richard Chamberlain, he recorded an album of love songs, and Philip had brought this, and then he started the music.
简已经完全进入了假新娘的状态。当菲利普陪她进入汽车旅馆房间时，她没有叫他离开。他把她的唱片机带到了这个显然现在属于我们俩、而不是我一个人的汽车旅馆房间里。当时有一个叫《基尔德博士》的电视剧，这个演员理查德·张伯伦录制了一张情歌专辑，菲利普把这个带来了，然后他放起了音乐。
And he got out of volume of late Victorian poetry, and he had picked out some very romantic poems, which he read to me. Through the valley, depths of shade, of night and dark obscurity, where the path has lost its way, where the sun forgets the day. As Richard Chamberlain was singing softly in the background.
他拿出一卷晚期维多利亚时代的诗集，挑选了一些非常浪漫的诗读给我听。穿过山谷，幽暗的树荫深处，夜色与黑暗朦胧，小径迷失了方向，太阳遗忘了白昼。当理查德·张伯伦在背景中轻声歌唱时。
Then trace thy footsteps on with me were wed to one eternity. Rea stars will shine tonight, one for the long. I mean, I'm sure he did this to make it a very sweet romantic evening. And so I, you know, went along with it. It's almost like you must get the sense that he's sort of wooing you at this point. I mean, sort of a bit of an odd thing to have a wedding celebration before you start wooing someone, but presumably that's what he was doing. It was exactly what he was doing. If he hadn't already given me the diamond ring, that would
然后与我一同追随你的足迹，我们结合于永恒。今晚繁星将闪耀，为了那漫长的……我的意思是，他这么做肯定是为了营造一个非常甜蜜浪漫的夜晚。所以，你知道的，我就顺从了。你几乎会有一种感觉，他此时此刻正在追求你。我的意思是，在开始追求某人之前先举行婚礼庆祝活动有点奇怪，但据推测这就是他当时在做的事。这正是他在做的事。如果他当时还没把钻戒给我，那
have been the time he whipped it out. You know there was a part of me that appreciated the trouble he had gone through to make this What he anticipated would be a romantic experience for me and certainly it gave me a sense of what he considered romantic So it's almost weird you still thought of him as being a nice guy. I Did isn't that something? Yeah I did, isn't that something? Yeah. Yeah. I felt almost like a little puppet in his puppet show.
就是他掏出钻戒的时候了。你知道，我内心有一部分很感激他为了创造他所预期的对我来说是浪漫体验而经历的麻烦，当然，这让我了解了什么是他认为的浪漫。所以这甚至有点诡异，你仍然觉得他是个好人。我确实觉得，这不是挺特别的吗？是的，我确实觉得，这不是挺特别的吗？是的。是的。我感觉自己就像他木偶戏里的一个小木偶。
And as long as he wasn't going to throw me to the floor, cut my strings or whatever, I was going to be okay. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. As the graduation weekend unfolded, Jains' understanding of what was happening merged into the narrative that Philip had constructed. The social proof she received told her how she was expected to behave, and the scripts inside her head kept her from challenging the narrative. The more people Philip recruited to the charade, the harder it became for Jane to step outside it. To stop it. The next morning,
只要他不把我摔到地上、剪断我的线或者别的什么，我就会没事的。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。随着毕业周末的展开，简对正在发生的事情的理解融入了菲利普构建的叙事中。她受到的社会认同告诉她应该如何表现，而她脑海中的剧本则阻止她挑战这种叙事。菲利普招募进这场闹剧的人越多，简就越难跳出它。想要阻止它。第二天早上，
Sunday, Jane woke up with Philip in bed with her. In less than 48 hours, the unthinkable had become unremarkable. It was graduation day. We were to meet Philip's mother and sister at a cafe just off the campus there for brunch. When they arrived at the cafe, Philip's mother and sister were waiting outside. He introduced me and we went in as I say and we sat down.
星期天，简醒来时发现菲利普和她睡在同一张床上。在不到48小时的时间里，不可思议的事情已经变得微不足道了。今天是毕业典礼日。我们要和菲利普的母亲和妹妹在校园附近的一家咖啡馆吃早午餐。当他们到达咖啡馆时，菲利普的母亲和妹妹正等在外面。他做了介绍，我们走进去，就像我说的，我们坐下了。
Jane sat next to Philip's sister on the inside of the booth. Philip sat across from her and Philip's mother sat next to him. Jane prayed this was finally the moment Philip would drop the charade. But then he said to his mom, Mom, I want you to meet my wife. And I had been so sure that once his family arrived, the charade would be over and we could go on as just friends, you know, a friend of his who was there just for the graduation. And I couldn't bear it at that point I did crack. I said no. No. I'm sorry. No, I'm not his wife. He's teasing. He's pretending.
简坐在卡座里面靠着菲利普的妹妹。菲利普坐在她对面，菲利普的母亲坐在他旁边。简祈祷这终于会是菲利普放弃这场闹剧的时刻。但接着他对妈妈说：“妈，我想让你见见我妻子。”我之前那么确信，一旦他的家人到来，闹剧就会结束，我们就可以作为普通朋友继续相处，你知道的，只是一个碰巧为参加毕业典礼而去的他的朋友。那一刻我再也承受不住了，我崩溃了。我说：“不。不。对不起。不，我不是他妻子。他在开玩笑。他在假装。”
And Philip laughed and he just said to his mom, oh, come on. She's just not used to being my wife. And so she's still a little self-conscious about it, but she is. We're married. And I tried. I said, no, wait. Well, his mother leapt up with this dreadful look on her face, and she literally ran out of that cafe. out of that cafe. And he ran after her. And I was almost in tears at that point. I turned to his sister and I said, please understand me.
菲利普笑了，他对妈妈说：“哦，得了吧。她只是还不习惯做我的妻子。所以她还有点不好意思，但她确实是。我们结婚了。”我试过了。我说：“不，等等。”这时，他母亲脸上带着可怕的表情猛地站起来，她字面意义上跑出了那家咖啡馆。跑出了那家咖啡馆。他追了出去。那一刻我几乎要哭出来了。我转向他妹妹说：“请理解我。
I'm telling you the truth. I'm not married to your brother. I hardly know him. Her look was so understanding and sad. And she said, it's not your fault. It really isn't your fault. And she got up and went out to her mom and let her mom away.
我跟你说的是实话。我根本没有和你哥哥结婚。我几乎不认识他。”她的表情是那么理解和悲伤。她说：“这不是你的错。真的不是你的错。”她站起来，走了出去找她妈妈，把她妈妈带走了。
And I'm wondering at this point after his mom and sister leave, isn't this the point that you basically say, you know what Philip enough is enough? point after his mom and sister leave, isn't this the point that you basically say, you know what Philip enough is enough? Yeah, you know, at that point, I was just so exhausted, I just didn't have the energy to stand up to him. It was as I said before, step by step, each time getting deeper into this, this farce. It was like, how could I back
我在想，在他妈妈和妹妹离开后，这难道不是你基本上说“你知道吗，菲利普，够了”的时刻吗？在他妈妈和妹妹离开后，这难道不是你基本上说“你知道吗，菲利普，够了”的时刻吗？是的，你知道，在那一刻，我实在是太累了，根本没有精力去顶撞他。就像我之前说的，一步接一步，每一次都让我更深地陷入这场闹剧。当时的感觉是，我怎么可能在那时
out by then? I mean, I got to go to, he's taking me to the campus for graduation and I couldn't have demanded that he take me to the train station at that point, because he was about to graduate. I know that sounds bizarre, but it's true. Jane had finally spoken up at the cafe. She had stood up to fill up, but he refused to acknowledge what she had done. He acted as if she had said nothing. I didn't say anything to him until we got to the campus and he told me to go get a good seat and I said yes or whatever.
退缩呢？我的意思是，我要去，他正带我去校园参加毕业典礼，我当时不可能要求他送我去火车站，因为他马上就要毕业了。我知道这听起来很离谱，但这是真的。简终于在咖啡馆里开口了。她对菲利普进行了反抗，但他拒绝承认她所做的一切。他表现得好像她什么也没说一样。直到我们到了校园，他让我去找个好座位，我说“好”或者别的什么，我才跟他说过话。
The graduation was outdoors. Jane found a seat in a row of folding chairs close to the stage. In front of her were a set of wooden bleachers, where the graduates would soon take their places. I remember I was kind of rolling and unrolling the order of ceremony, because I didn't even know what to do with my hands. I was just wishing it were all over. I was just waiting for it to end. You know, I think there was beginning to be an undercurrent of resentment that Philip put me into this. You know, I think I was getting pissed off. But then, at that point, what are you going to do?
毕业典礼是在户外举行的。简在靠近舞台的一排折叠椅上找到一个座位。她前面是一排木制看台，毕业生们很快就会在那里就座。我记得我一直在卷着和展开毕业典礼的秩序册，因为我甚至不知道该把手放在哪里。我只是希望这一切快点结束。我只是在等它结束。你知道，我想我内心开始对菲利普把我拉进这种境地产生了一种暗流涌动的怨恨。你知道，我想我当时气炸了。但即便如此，那种情况下你又能怎么办？
Stand up and yell to the whole college that this is all a farce? The seats around her began to fill up with happy, laughing families. Everyone was blissfully unaware of the drama-consuming Jane. And then this woman came and sidled down the row and it was Philip's sister. So I asked, you know, where's your mom? Doesn't she want to come sit with us? And I looked around and looked around and finally I saw her. She was way at the back behind even the last row of the audience.
站起来向全校大喊这一切都是个闹剧吗？她周围的座开始坐满幸福、欢笑的家人。每个人都全然不知吞噬着简的戏剧性。然后这个女人走过来，顺着这一排挤过来，是菲利普的妹妹。所以我问，你知道，你妈妈在哪儿？她不想过来和我们一起坐吗？我环顾四周，看了又看，最后我看到了她。她甚至在观众最后一排的后面，远远地待在最后面。
And she couldn't stop moving and she couldn't stop moving. She couldn't stop moving. Her shoulders were kind of rocking, and she was like holding her purse up against her heart and kind of rocking from foot to foot. And it was clear she was very distraught. he was very distraught. Graduates began to file in two by two in their caps and gowns.
她完全停不下来，根本停不下来。她就是停不下来。她的肩膀在微微颤抖，她把钱包紧紧贴在胸口，两只脚不停地前后晃动。很明显，她非常心神不定。她非常心神不定。毕业生们戴着学士帽，穿着学士服，两人一组开始排队入场。
As they took their seats on the bleachers, Jane spotted Philip sitting down with a group of his fraternity brothers. He looked around at first until he could find me and then he saw my face and he gave a face, and he gave a little discreet wave, and I just kind of automatically smiled back at him, but it wasn't a real smile. I just, it's like, okay, as the Italians would say,
当他们在看台落座时，简一眼看到菲利普正和他的几个兄弟会学长坐在一起。他先是环顾四周，直到找到我，接着他看到了我的脸，露出了一个表情，然后非常低调地朝我挥了挥手。我几乎是本能地朝他微笑回应，但这并不是一个真正的微笑。我只是觉得，好吧，就像意大利人会说的那样：
a Lord, a Lord, a Lord Lord, get on with it. Ha, ha, ha, ha. Ah. The college presidents stood at a podium and began to give the usual ceremonial speech. How all the graduates would succeed, how they would go on to do great things. Then he kind of got into the more personal and he looked out at the audience and he said, you know, today is not just an auspicious day in the lives of our graduates,
“天哪，天哪，我的天哪，快点结束吧。”哈哈哈哈。啊。大学校长站在演讲台前，开始发表常规的庆典致辞。讲着毕业生们将如何获得成功，如何去成就伟大的事业。随后，他的语气变得更加私人化，他望向台下的观众说道：“大家知道，今天不仅是我们毕业生人生中大吉大利的日子，
but it's also a very special day for their parents. And I would like to invite all the fathers in the audience to rise and be recognized for their loving support. The fathers stood laughing and groaning at all the attention. And he said, let's not forget the mothers. You have sacrificed as well. And may all the mothers please stand. And they did, and there was more applause and whistles. And I had the most horrible, horrible realization that something was going to happen next.
同时也是他们父母非常特别的一天。我想邀请台下所有的父亲起立，接受大家对他们充满爱意的支持的致敬。”父亲们起立，伴随着掌声与嘘声，对这突如其来的关注感到既好笑又尴尬。校长接着说：“别忘了母亲们。你们同样付出了牺牲。请所有的母亲们起立。”她们照做了，现场响起了更热烈的掌声和口哨声。而我内心涌起了一种无比可怕、极其糟糕的直觉，觉得接下来要发生什么事了。
I just knew it was like a premonition and sure enough, he continued and he said, quite a few of our students have spouses who have helped bring to fruition the dream of a college diploma. And would all the wives and husbands marry to a graduate please stand and accept the honor that you are to. And at that point I froze. I physically froze. I couldn't stand up. I wouldn't stand up. And I heard, you know, the noise and the bustle of several young men and women standing up in the audience. And I thought, no, no, I'm I'm not gonna do this I will not do this but I looked up at Philip and he was moving his hands he was lifting his hands you know palm up like saying you should stand up then next I knew a couple of his fraternity brothers were doing the same damn thing. They're lifting their hands up, smiling these big smiles. Come on, come on, get up. You're as newly wedded pride.
我就是有这种预感，果不其然，他继续说道：“我们的许多学生都有伴侣，是他们帮助实现了大学毕业文凭的梦想。请所有嫁给毕业生的妻子和娶了毕业生的丈夫起立，接受你们应得的荣誉。”就在那一刻，我僵住了。我的身体完全僵住了。我站不起来。我不想站起来。我听到观众席中传来几个年轻人起立时的喧闹和嘈杂声。我心想：不，不，我不会这么做的，我绝对不干这事。但我抬头看着菲利普，他正挥舞着双手，把手掌朝上举起，那意思好像在说“你应该站起来”。紧接着，我发现他身边的几个兄弟会成员也在做着同样该死的事情。他们举起双手，脸上挂着灿烂的笑容：“来吧，来吧，起来吧。你可是新婚燕尔的骄傲啊。”
I got up. And then this horrible, screaming moan rang out over the entire audience. I'm so glad I was able to get back to the end of the story. I'm so glad I was able to get back to the end of the story. I'm so glad I was able to get back to the end of the story. I'm so glad I was able to get back to the end of the story. I sank back onto my chair, just as Philip's sister jumped up and slipped out along the row and ran back to find their mother. Do you remember Philip driving you back to the train station or how you got home that weekend? I remember getting out of the car at the train station and getting on the train and being so grateful that the weekend was over.
我站了起来。紧接着，全场爆发出一声极其恐怖、刺耳的惨叫。我真高兴自己能回到这个故事的结尾。我真高兴自己能回到这个故事的结尾。我真高兴自己能回到这个故事的结尾。我真高兴自己能回到这个故事的结尾。我一屁股跌坐回椅子上，就在这时，菲利普的妹妹猛地跳起来，顺着长排溜了出去，跑去找他们的母亲。你还记得菲利普开车送你回火车站，还是那个周末你是怎么回家的？我只记得在火车站下了车，坐上了火车，心中无比庆幸这个周末终于结束了。
I never wrote to him again and he never wrote to me or called me, it was over. It was over. I had played a role in his drama, and there was no reason for him to ever write and say, or here's why I did it or nothing, nothing. It was like it never happened if I didn't ever tell anybody about it. For a long time Jane didn't tell anybody about it, but then for perhaps the first time in her life she started to question the scripts in her head that told her to brush what had happened under the rug. She started to interrogate how she had behaved.
我再也没有给他写过信，他也没有给我写过信或打过电话，一切都结束了。一切都结束了。我只是在他自导自演的戏码里扮演了一个角色，他没有任何理由再写信解释或者说明他为什么要这么做，什么都没有，什么都没有。如果我从来没有把这件事告诉任何人，它就好像从未发生过一样。很长一段时间里，简没有把这件事告诉任何人，但后来，也许是她生平第一次，她开始质疑脑海中的那些“剧本”——是它们告诉她要把发生过的事情粉饰太平。她开始审视自己的行为。
There was no question Philip had behaved horribly and that he had put her in a very difficult situation. She was the victim. But Jane decided she didn't want to see herself as a mere victim. How would she allow things to go as far as they had? It was painful to step outside herself to look at the scripts she had internalized. To realize, she had allowed herself to become a puppet
毫无疑问，菲利普的行为极其恶劣，他把她置于一个非常艰难的境地。她是受害者。但简决定，她不想把自己仅仅视为一个受害者。她怎么会允许事情发展到这种地步？跳出自我去审视那些内化在心中的剧本，这个过程是痛苦的。去意识到自己居然允许自己变成一个木偶，
in someone else's play. I just know that it was a terrible shame for me that I went along with that, with any of it. I just know that it was a terrible shame for me that I went along with that, with any of it. I mean, I became a stranger. I was like a hypnotized person. I wasn't me, and yet I was. I felt like I had lost touch with who I was
任由别人摆布。我只知道，我竟然顺从了这一切，顺从了其中的任何一部分，这对我来说简直是个巨大的耻辱。我只知道，我竟然顺从了这一切，顺从了其中的任何一部分，这对我来说简直是个巨大的耻辱。我的意思是，我变得像个陌生人。我当时就像被催眠了一样。那不是我，却又确实是我。我觉得自己已经失去了真实的自我，
that I was somebody else. I was my shadow side or something. I don't know. I just became this strange person who just did what she was told, even when she knew it hurt other people. That weekend, awful though it was, was the start of Jane's journey to find out which script she wanted in her head and which ones to discard. She realized she had spent a lifetime going along with the wishes of other people, suppressing her own needs, dancing away from difficult conversations. Jane began to ask herself questions that many people spend a lifetime avoiding.
感觉自己成了另一个人。我仿佛变成了自己阴暗的一面什么的。我不知道。我只是变成了这个奇怪的人，只会盲目听从别人的吩咐，即便明知这样做会伤害到别人。那个周末虽然糟糕透顶，却是简踏上寻找之旅的起点——她开始弄清楚自己脑海里究竟想要保留哪个剧本，又该抛弃哪些剧本。她意识到自己一生都在顺从别人的愿望，压抑自己的需求，逃避艰难的对话。简开始问自己许多人穷极一生都在逃避的问题。
Who am I? Who do I want to be? I started letting more of my own wishes determine what I was going to do rather than always being concerned primarily by what would my parents think, you know, if they knew about this. Susan Crawford was Jane's best friend during this period of transformation. We lived in the same dorm, a couple of doors down. And I think we both had the same thought
我是谁？我想成为什么样的人？我开始让更多我自己的愿望来决定我要做什么，而不是总是主要顾虑“如果我父母知道了这件事，他们会怎么想”。苏珊·克劳福德是简在这一转变时期的挚友。我们住在同一个宿舍，隔了几扇门。我想我们当时都有着相同的想法，
during our freshman orientation week, which was that this was not the place for either one of us. As they went through college, Jane discovered a new site to herself. She and Susan even developed a rebellious trick. The president of our college commissioned a sculptor to do a piece called The Spirit of Woman, which Jane and I
那就是在我们大一入学的新生周里，觉得这里根本不适合我们两个。在大学期间，简发现自己性格中崭新的一面。她和苏珊甚至还策划了一个叛逆的恶作剧。我们学校的校长曾委托一位雕塑家创作了一件名为《女性精神》的作品，简和我
always called the Golden Bagel. And it was roughly shaped like a bagel. And so first we thought we'd put dishwasher liquid in the water of the fountain and just have it bubble up. And then we decided, no, that's that's just too tame. And we went out and got a lot of lighter fluid and just coated the whole thing with lighter fluid and then threw a match at it. and it went up in a sheet of blue flame. It was glorious. Jane initially didn't tell Susan about what happened that crazy weekend. But one evening, after they had both graduated from college, Jane finally revealed the truth.
总是把它叫做“金色百吉饼”。它的外形大致就像一个百吉饼。所以我们最初的想法是在喷泉的水里倒进洗洁精，让它泛起泡沫。后来我们决定，不，那实在是太温和了。于是我们出去买了很多打火机油，把整个雕塑都涂满了打火机油，然后扔了一根火柴上去。它瞬间燃起了一片蓝色的火焰。太壮观了。简起初并没有把那个疯狂周末发生的事告诉苏珊。但有一天晚上，在两人大学毕业后，简终于吐露了真相。
I can remember her being a little... I won't say reluctant, but being a little careful about telling the story. And I do recall her saying, I don't know why I didn't tell you this earlier. I think I was so embarrassed. But now I'd like to tell you. Susan of course was shocked. The Jane she had come to know seemed so different that the innocent teenager Philip had manipulated. They both puzzled over what might have prompted Philip to invent such a crazy story. What was this all about? And why did he need Jane? Did he interpret her graciousness as weakness that he could pray upon?
我记得她当时有点……我不会说是不情愿，但讲述这个故事时显得有些小心翼翼。我的确记得她说：“我不知道为什么我没有早点告诉你。我想我当时太尴尬了。但现在我想告诉你。”苏珊当然震惊了。她所认识的简，与那个被菲利普操纵的天真少女截然不同。她们俩百思不得其解，究竟是什么促使菲利普编造出这么一个疯狂的故事？这到底是怎么回事？他又为什么需要简？难道他把她的温和有礼当成了可以趁火打劫的软弱吗？
To this day, Jane wonders the same thing. I start now to think back to the time when he came to our house, to get to know me as almost an audition, to kind of assure himself that I would go along with this? I don't know. We tracked down Philip to his college. We found a photograph of him from 1962. He's wearing a tie and jacket. He has dark hair, the hint of a smile, and an earnest expression. We couldn't find much else about him and his life after his college graduation. We don't know why he staged the marriage. Given the hints of mental instability that marked his weekend with Jane,
直到今天，简还在纳闷同样的事情。我开始回想当年他来到我们家，想借此了解我，那简直就像是一次试镜，好让他自己确信我会配合这一切？我不知道。我们找到了菲利普所在的大学。我们找到了他1962年的一张照片。照片里的他穿着领带和夹克。他留着深色头发，带着一丝微笑，神情十分专注。关于他大学毕业后的生活，我们没有找到太多其他信息。我们不知道他为什么要刻意导演这场“婚礼”。鉴于他在那个周末同简相处时表现出的精神不稳定迹象，
we decided not to identify him by his real name. Jane now lives in California and has been happily married for more than 40 years. She has kids and grandkids she dots on and she has a radio show about mythology. It's called questing and she's really passionate about it. She's become an entirely different person than the naive girl she was that weekend in college. I've turned out to be quite not forceful, but I stick up for myself. I stick up for my family and my friends
我们决定不使用他的真实姓名。简现在住在加利福尼亚州，已经幸福地结婚四十多年了。她有疼爱的孩子和孙辈，还有一个关于神话节目的广播节目。节目名字叫《寻觅》，她对它充满了热情。她已经完全变成了另一个人，不再是大学那个周末里天真无邪的女孩了。我变得……不能说是咄咄逼人，但我会为自己挺身而出。我会为我的家人和朋友挺身而出，
and I feel like a pretty strong person at this. In fact, I feel like a really strong person in my life. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Autumn Barnes, Ryan Katz, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our run song hero today is my mom Watsalaala Vedanta. She gave me my love for language, but she also showed me, through example, what it means to carve out a life for yourself. She broke many rules and thought for herself.
我觉得自己在这个过程中变得相当坚强。事实上，我觉得自己在生活中是个非常坚强的人。《隐秘大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、奥特曼·巴恩斯、瑞安·卡茨、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔和安德鲁·查德里克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐秘大脑》的执行主编。我们今天的幕后英雄是我妈妈瓦萨拉·维丹塔。她培养了我对语言的热爱，但她也通过实际行动向我展示了，为自己开辟一条人生道路意味着什么。她打破了许多清规戒律，并且拥有独立思考的能力。
She challenged the scripts inside her own head and taught me I could do the same. This episode has made me think of all the ways the world teaches us how to act and think and the vital importance of learning to be your own person. I'm so grateful to my mother for starting me on that journey. Some of our best stories come to us from our listeners. If you have a story like the one you heard today that you are willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience, please find a quiet room and record a short voice memo on your phone. Email it to us at ideasat HiddenBrain.org using the subject line, Personal Story.
她挑战了自己脑海中的种种剧本，并教会了我也可以这样做。这一集让我开始思考，世界是如何全方位地教导我们该如何行事、如何思考的，而学会成为独立的自我又是多么至关重要。我非常感谢我的母亲引领我踏上了这段旅程。我们一些最精彩的故事都来自于我们的听众。如果你也有像今天听到的那样愿意与《隐秘大脑》听众分享的故事，请找一个安静的房间，在手机上录下一段简短的语音备忘录。发送电子邮件至 ideas@HiddenBrain.org，主题行请写：个人故事。
The best stories reveal honesty, vulnerability and moments of transformation. We are especially interested in stories that left you with more questions than answers. Again, that email address is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. If you like the story, please be sure to share this episode with three friends. If they are new to podcasting, please show them how to subscribe to our show. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
最棒的故事展现了诚实、脆弱以及蜕变的时刻。我们对那些让你留下更多疑问而非答案的故事尤为感兴趣。再次重申，电子邮箱地址是 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。如果你喜欢这个故事，请务必将这一集分享给三位朋友。如果他们是播客新手，请教教他们如何订阅我们的节目。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。我们下周见。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。